falsifier beaucoup de bulletins
scolaires c'est vrai je continue de
croire je peux devenir une rock star ce
faux
c'est vrai la seule fois de notre vie on
s'est disputés
on avait décidé de partir en croisière
avec nos femmes
n'importe quoi l'idée pourtant on
s'entend très bien et encore aujourd'hui
depuis 30 ans mais le problème c'est
qu'olivier donc il avait arrêté de fumer
et olivier quand ils arrêtent de fumer
et c'est pendant un jeu de société vous
rendez compte ou pas un truc de conquois
ont joué je sais pas quels jeux de
société et c'est parti on s'est vraiment
pris la tête
je m'appelle vraiment cad
sais mais c'est quand même cas de
biscuits kaddour fait partie de cad
quand j'ai fait ma première émission de
radio alors ça je devais c'était il ya
très longtemps sur une radio qui
s'appelle canal 102 je sais qu'on m'a
fait une réflexion du style à cadours ça
sonne un peu trop ému si c'est pour
faire de la radio c'est une radio qui
passe et de la funk c'était très ça me
faisait un peu radios américaines dont
je me suis appelé le première fois même
s'était même pas cad c'était mr cad
regardez je suis bourré de problèmes
d'attention est d'ailleurs très souvent
d'ailleurs pour toujours pas pour mieux
capter si tout d'un coup il ya un truc
hop je peux passer à autre chose et
c'est pareil pour le téléphone chargé au
fait j'en ai fait une fois je vais même
oublié dans le frigo
le parcours de mon propre de mondement
de mon personnage dans un triomphe c'est
à dire ses années de galère qu'on peut
avoir avant de rencontrer le beau projet
le beau le succès peut-être mais surtout
un vrai projet qui vous fait vivre quoi
parce qu'un acteur c'est c'est pas qu'un
mec connu c'est aussi un homme qui
travaille il faut travailler il faut
faire ses heures il faut il faut avoir
des projets et c'est difficile et moi
j'ai connu tous moments où avant de
faire mon premier film j'en ai fait des
pièges j'en ai bouffé des compagnies
j'en ai bouffé des petites scènes j'en
ai bouffé des salles vides mais ça ça
fait partie du métier d'acteur
c'est vrai
mais pas pour y travailler pour faire le
con
son plaisir universalis n'avait pas
connu ça vous ça valait une blinde et
j'ai réussi à le vendre à un copain
dentiste une fois c'est invendable t on
aller chez des gens bonjour madame voilà
je viens vous proposer une ça coûte et
4500 offrant ce qui est aujourd'hui peut
paraître peu mais à l'époque c'était
beaucoup d'argent et je me souviens que
je galérais mais ça fait partie de la
vie aussi ça
oui c'est vrai j'ai mais je continue de
croire je pourrais devenir une rock star
je continue de faire de la musique je
continue de croire je peux devenir une
rock star
n oui j'avais jamais bien en fait c'est
une chanson avant avant que ce soit
avant que le type soit soit arrêté pour
pédophilie là l'auteur se sert kelly
comme avec en prison où il ya plein de
problèmes je crois que je vais arrêter
de le chanter
ce faux ce qu'il faut aussi d'ailleurs
c'est que j'aurai soutenu ségolène royal
c'est marrant c'est que c'est truc me
suis maintenant j'ai rien contre
ségolène royal je suis pas du tout
politiquement je suis très apolitique
oui je pleure de belle de frank capra
oui je pleure devant à la première
seconde oui parce que je sais ce qui va
arriver oui parce que c'est un film qui
me bouleverse il ya tout dedans et
j'aime beaucoup ce film est et il est
très peu et même beaucoup
bien pleurer devant quelque chose
retraité de footix sais ce que c'est un
footix c'est un mec qui est cap qui
supportent tout le monde en fait je suis
je pense je suis le supporter idéal on
devrait avoir ça dans les stades
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire la vérité
je viens de saint-etienne jeu j'ai
grandi dans la région de saint-etienne
et mon père a le coeur vert donc mon
père c'est mon père dont je peux pas je
peux pas supporter notre équipe dans le
coeur donc c'est saint-etienne j'ai
habité à marseille j'adore marseille
j'habite à paris je continue de regarder
des matchs avec paris quand ils sont
beaux quand c'est des matches importants
beaucoup de bulletins scolaires parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas bons mon père c'est
très sévère donc j'ai tellement peur de
ce qu'elle aime arrivé que j'étais prêt
à devenir un faussaire plutôt que de
devenir un amoché
les boîtes oui oui c'est vrai mais
discale et c'était à l'époque les
disquettes pour des jeux vidéo quant à
l'époque les jeux vidéo tu es sur
disquette j'ai fait ce boulot là pendant
pendant quelque temps et je me rappelle
ont été payés à la boîte donc il fallait
il faire super vite c'était un copain du
cours de théâtre qui m'avait dit si tu
veux gagner un peu d'argent j'ai un plan
c c'est des petits boulots qu'on fait
quand on est jeune et quand on a besoin
d'eux de payer son loyer au pays son
cours de théâtre donc oui j'ai emballé
des disquettes dans des boîtes